you know maybe I should just give you
guys something you guys will talk after
this I'm waste em wasting your hammer
time hi I'm Greg hi John when do you
leave from the movie couple channel a
channel for all you lovers out there
like movies and she's also from the
Collider videos channel she will be the
next Schmoe down champion I am ensuring
this I'm her trainer for that now
it's coach me hard so you're on a movie
channel so I'm assuming you've heard of
King Kong right of course
well that's why you're here today John
and you and I proper sentence
fragmentations we're gonna watch the
Kong Skull Island rise of the King Trail
oh boy is supposed to the final trailer
considering the movie comes out in like
a week or two and the first person
requests this trailer that's on the
comics me lover number one me lover
number two oh they could have called
Europe movie couple channel the movie
lovers cuz it would have been a spin on
loving movies and you're both lovers
well maybe you were like one of you is
moving over one and one of you is movie
lover too and then when you've got
married you decided to become the movie
that was her husband comment it doesn't
have does soon and dick gonna love it
have you guys liked all the trailers so
far I like the first one the second one
no the third one more than the last oh
yeah and I like the clips we saw on one
trail I didn't like
I also postponed doing this reaction
because Wendy was coming by and I wanted
to make sure yeah worthwhile tie yeah
and I made sure I avoided it all day
today yeah I text her bright and early
in the morning watch it
[Music]
uncharted island let me list all the
ways you got to die grain heat disease
carrying flies come he hadn't started on
the things that want of it your life
will double that plus a bonus if we make
it back wow this really does have an
apocalypse now
[Music]
whoa Wow
is so cool and they got their QV whoa
kidding that was a great slip Lewis
Howes skull crores
okay everybody sounds neat okay look I
just made that name up we're trying to
scare you I'm fine calling than that are
you going yeah
oh this is the best trailer oh my gosh
I'm sold
yes right I'll go after that girl just
back into nothing
[Music]
it's so good that was the best trailer I
had after this yeah we do
that was the best show that they've had
holy wow he's definitely better that was
it had all the right tone down it's like
everything we saw prior like start fully
just you grasp it and it's the banter
style the comedy style introducing that
up front and then you're seeing like oh
this is how it does feel like a populist
snappy I like the musical cues that was
energy that I'm at them with the picture
oh wow that whole helicopter see when
they all show up and he sees him through
his lens John Goodman that like even
though we my sauce snippets of that
treatment I was like that looks like a
really intense sequence yeah and the
cool thing about this is that it is kind
of like cool [ __ ] overload personally I
would have ended this trailer like
thirty seconds earlier there was a point
where I was like this looks awesome
and then they showed me like a bunch
more awesome stuff so by the time I got
to the end he like full-on made a sword
out of a tree I was like really I hope
you don't get too I like that I like
that color getting yeah it crossed a
point of silliness for me whereas like
it got a little silly towards me which
isn't isn't necessarily bad I just like
I wish it would have stopped I wish that
could have been a surprise like I wish
the movie would have a chance to earn
that instead of me having an idea about
it now but as a badass trailer man like
the first part of that trailer like
getting the vibe across doing like you
said that Apocalypse Now it very like in
the trenches sort of vivid war movie and
it and little scene at the front where
we finally get a little more on Tommy
it'll stand way up in that crazy like
we're understanding or our hero is now
yeah like expressions like like you're
starting to get a sense for who the
ensemble is and it looks wicked cool
like it does it feels like these are
times that have a sense of humor to
repress our dark the times are really
feeling the whole 70s vibe to it what
was your favorite part I can't get with
the whole thing especially the
helicopter scene yeah when they were
going down and all of a sudden you see
calling like pick them up you're like oh
my god can this be more epic I can't
wait to see this on the big screen oh
yeah
max I'm gonna throw my money that's the
shot with a POV when is John set like
that they're singing that to ya there's
a cool POV spinning shot that they added
to it by showing like ocean throws kick
oh yeah it was like being up the ride
again when they had a Universal Studios
just bring the bandra well yeah dude
that was all like the old studio tour
that used to freak me out nobody's visit
like when everyone come into the the
actual soundstage and animatronic um
freaked me out
and watching this kind of gave me that
feeling yeah yeah it feels like a fun
ride and I'm terrified but you're
excited see ya see this thing this is
fun to me because like we get a lot of
these big familiar proper property
blockbuster movies and the thing is like
this trailer actually like ah I was
caught up and I was excited and I got
that feeling like when I was a kid
looking at the animatronic Kong so I was
like well done on you for really making
it like want to go to a theater and see
this big sweepy things you know this
could be a great
he's like a fun monster wrong for sure I
know how how excited are you to see Kong
vs. Godzilla I'm pretty I mean I'm wait
till after this movie yeah
I wait for things when I first heard
Batman and Superman were coming together
so I'm really cool too till it's awesome
works those things again well that's the
thing about this - sighs I really liked
Gareth Edwards Godzilla yeah and it did
well and this you know is the first new
Kong movie we've had since Peter Jackson
so it's like we're rebranding Kong and I
also just get the sense that while
Godzilla did well people were like oh we
had some notes Friel oh yeah hey come on
seems you know like so I feel like
Godzilla 2 is gonna change also yeah so
yeah it's like I want to see I'll be
excited to see the matchup when I
understand what's going on with the
other two movies first is movie tomorrow
I hope this is as awesome as it was it
seemed like they were including cuz when
I heard I read an interview with the
director he's like we've seen this story
done a billion times before you know
with the girl so we wanted to bring
something different freshen it sound
like they weren't gonna include that
part with King Kong fall in love with
the girl they don't have anything of him
like going back
to New York there were some moments
where it looked like he was like
rescuing brie Larson like one she at
that moment she's yeah his chest and
stuff so dude there is some connection
there's some attraction that brie Larson
has no King Kong I mean why wouldn't you
is big black Darden handsome dude is
everything you want in the dark man you
know ah King Kong monster movie wrapped
inside us 70s horror movie yeah with get
out coming out recently and this this is
perfect I know and all the black people
sweeping the Oscars
this is this is good the controversial
part of the video okay here John Kevin
John doesn't like jokes I'm just not
sure where the jug and I don't know how
propria or not the joke really is so I
don't want to touch I'm kidding are you
guys - no I'm kidding
they went all out just like some editor
just had a blast yeah I got this trailer
together props to them like this dude
whoever cut this if this is one guy or
several people maybe even a woman cut I
don't know whoever cut this this is
they're rocking out these this whoever's
dis getting jobs this trailer the number
one thing it did differently for me was
it got me excited for every part of this
movie yes yeah yeah before everybody's
like there are things that look cool not
too sure about this I don't know what to
think of this this got me excited for
everything the way it shot looks
beautiful and most importantly got me
excited to see King Kong kick some ass
yeah as of this trailer I feel like
something from every piece of this movie
I've seen now kind of works a little me
yeah the last one built some goodwill
and this one made me want to go so so I
feel like I got it it's done a good job
recontextualizing the stuff they've
already shown us so is this like the
final trailer for for King Kong I hope
they release one more oh give us like we
wanted to make good trailer yeah but
that but I felt like this straight I
mean what everyone's been so lucky calm
but this trick did something differently
for me right now I'm like II okay
alright is forced trailer but this one I
was like oh that's a pretty sweet ray
listen the whole message is on you
have to see like because it is like it's
your gonna be Universal Studios you know
in a theater yeah yeah let's do it
laughs again for your wedding I'm so
glad I waited to watch those so worth it
cause our feel like just just finally
like with an old property like calm it's
like even if you whatever every time
they touch King Kong even if people
don't like it I never get the sense that
they're like just kind of [ __ ] all
over what the legacy of Kong is like
they're always interesting in a way and
I feel like this is continuing that oh
that's that's a cool thing
so hopefully the respect you know how
much you guys think this will make in
the box office opening weekend six
twenty million dollars I'll go I go
third 60o sixty what weekend the way we
were yeah when is the mortgage this is
March 10th so what else is coming out
that weekend
I'll give it Beauty and the Beast is the
week after Marion crane forty so this
may not have that much competition no I
don't think it will think I'm gonna go
I'm go to a 55 something tells me the
Kong Skull Island audience and the
Beauty and the Beast audience are a
little different from each other but it
will deal with a month actually are
similar daddy at least and a woman
Beauty killed the Beast that is an
example of two films working together
never mind
do you think will subscribe to the real
rejects for fun facts or something
John is reasons to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram is a social media manager of
the real rejects and Blum House Wendy
Lee is the star of the movie couple
Channel with her husband dusty easy
doesn't we call dusty i call dusty dusty
yes about destiny pan
someone's called on the floor at
custodian dust Odeon stony dystopia does
Tina misty no I'm just gonna add
whatever that's called in the English
language when you add words does just a
dusting to speak more and she's also in
Collider videos you could catch her
there and the first person request this
trailer that's on the comics movie
lover number one we love her number two
oh they could have called Europe movie
couple channel the movie lovers cuz it
would have been a spin on loving movies
and you're both lovers well maybe you
were like one of you is moving over one
and one of you is movie lover too and
then when you got married you decided to
become the movie that was her husband
who commented dustpan doesn't a man's
dick